foreign
I have a theory that Africans have this
hotline to Joy oh yeah we greet each
other we welcome each other absolutely
there's there's within us as a continent
there is great joy absolutely it's a
state of mind for us it's either laugh
or die we don't have the choice
and
that's where the Proverbs come from
that's where all those mimics sometimes
can be an insult or going get out of
here you're making a full of yourself
our body we have signs and we look at
each other and the situation it might be
a dire situation and then we start
laughing and go somebody have make a
huge mistake and you are in a date you
can even get yourself out and we laugh
and we help you at the same time that's
why I say it's a state of mind
I have seen people watch you perform and
they're in the audience they are
mesmerized they are smiling they are
joyful
do you have an awareness of what you are
doing to your audience
no I don't have any awareness because
for me every concert is a start over
I never take any public for granted
because you're never gonna you never
know what's the concert gonna be you can
have plan in your head you can have your
set list and everything
is just to help you it's just like um a
parameter that you put in there to be
able to perform but what happened after
that is out of your hands that's the
power of music when you when I'm holding
my microphone for me stage is My
Sanctuary
I was looking up some of the comments
people write when they watch it online
on YouTube now normally I wouldn't do
this but but this is fine this is not
scary Pure Love For Mama Angelique a
beautiful ball of energy
[Laughter]
you know what you're doing
well being on stage for me
is the most important thing I hate to be
in the studio
but I have to learn throughout the years
that I need to be in the studio to be
able to
perform to be on stage
and that energy that we're talking about
the public gave it to me I can't keep it
if I keep it I will explode I mean just
face it and I can't sleep like when I
finish a concert it take me like four
hours for me to dwindle down and to be
able to sleep is terrible and because
I'm wired up I don't need no drugs I
don't drink coffee I don't drink alcohol
I don't take anything I don't need it
the music is my drug so therefore when
I'm on stage
I'm just trying to convey the happiness
the joy
and the strength that we have as human
being
to Prevail in every circumstances
because music have shown me
when I'm facing the public
I see people from around the world
all different skin tones
and probably all people that speak
different languages
that make you humble and you've gone so
beyond what would be expected of someday
with your profile as a musician you are
not just a musician you're not just an
artist you are also an educator
education is everything
and
when I started this journey with my
Foundation by Tonga
one thing I have in mind is what my
father always used to say
an educated person
is a peacemaker
and it's true
because when you are educating and
understand the connectivity everything
in the world we live in is connected
even us
and if there's one thing we learned from
during the pandemic is that we cannot
live alone
lock down or not it becomes a point
where we need others to be able to
celebrate our own Humanity
from the moment I started going to
school it triggers something in me not
only the Curiosity but I was thirsty of
learning what can I learn every day and
I'll come home and ask questions and I'm
lucky enough to have
10 brothers and sisters that come before
some of them have been there so if I ask
questions somebody always gonna answer
me
and then
I get to high school
and I start seeing a different side of
Education
because when I finished Primary School
most of my girlfriend we made plan
when you get to high school we're gonna
do this we're gonna do that some of them
disappear from the radar
and I will ask the question asking the
question why aren't they here
then my girlfriend in the same street
where I grew up I was right across my
house
and I'm like Dad what is going on and
then he went and found out that he
should get married and I was it was a
day that I'm like is it worth living if
at that age you're gonna marry somebody
without me knowing what's going on
so to start my Foundation secondary
school is to allow those young girls to
buy time
to have a future to decide the future
they want to have instead of being
married young and end up dying on on a
delivering bed
so for me education not only
allow us to understand the complexity of
this world
it also Unleash the Power
that we have to understand when we stand
in front of Injustice
our rights what is right and what is
wrong
and when it comes to women
especially in the continent of Africa
I've started realizing that the vision
of my father
for women is totally different from the
vision of the father of my friends
because when I got to their home
I couldn't speak because it was not
allowed you have to be given permission
to speak one in my house you have
something in your mind go right ahead
somebody gonna answer you
and I start seeing the differences and I
said how we can how can we break
this cycle of
always women have to be the one they get
quiet and may speak up when even when
they're saying nonsenses
the patonga foundation it creates
opportunities for women and girls it
creates a future for them it sounds easy
though you have to say that creates
opportunities women and girls easy but
it's not it is
can you give us an example of
your advocacy work that has been
difficult
but you've worked for it and you've seen
success and happiness the other side
the hardest thing
when I started was not being able to
get the car to speak
it was breaking my heart
what is your name there's no answer they
look at you like
and I'm like why
why tell me what you need I'm here to
help I'm not going to tell you what to
do
from the day
they realize
and have confidence
that I'm not here to judge the choices
some of them were already mothers
and you have a lot of Pride when you're
talking to
on the privileged people
because I decided from the get-go
to work to dirt road where no one wants
to go
because that's where you have fewer
opportunities and I was not gonna let
those girls be marginalized and left in
in in the limbo
so from the moment they start speaking
to me
is the moment I start seeing how we can
move forward together
so we start
doing as an organization we needed a
data right
because I've done it 10 years to sending
people to high school they end up in
University all that kind of stuff
but I wanted to understand why
and the reason of the Dropout of the
girls
so through that we find out many
different reasons
one of the reasons of the Dropout is
that in Primary School the teacher were
not good enough
so they didn't have the tool to succeed
in Secondary School
and there's so much simulation you can
go through when you you appear to be a
stupid person and you're not stupid you
just don't have the tools then you drop
out
pregnancy of course and family poverty
and one thing that come out of that data
collection is
all of the girls say we need a safe
space
we need a place where we can talk to one
another
and we can work together and support one
another as it is done
so we start creating the girl club and
build an a curriculum based on their
needs
and they asked to be taught how to
prevent rape
how can they run away
how can they do things so we come up
with
a simple thing
don't go out when it's getting dark
when you're walking and you have a a
shadow behind you and you feel
uncomfortable don't start don't try to
be courageous don't try to be daring run
away and we prepared The Village if a
girl comes to the house
keep her there until the family member
can come because there's a danger in the
street so we start the whole thing like
that what is going on today
that I'm really proud of
is that those young girls
are becoming entrepreneur in creating
jobs
they are in total control of what they
do with their money
they decided they're gonna save money
it's not me
for the children not to go through this
again
what they want is to break the cycle of
poverty The Next Step that I'm taking is
to go to the northern part of my country
Benin
the girls in Benin are eight years old
Ascend to the man they're gonna marry
them home they become
made until they have the period then and
I want to break that cycle I've been
working hard I've been asking for help
for this for so long
we're gonna start there with local
organizations we don't bring anybody
from outside we work with the people
that knows the needs we work with the
village the the head of the villages the
mothers we want people to see for
themselves the progress we are making
and for them allow them to listen to the
kids that way they never do
what is the difference between the
pleasure you get from changing
a generation's life
to the pleasure of being on stage at a
major event performing and the crowd is
going wild what's the difference between
that kind of joy
there are two totally different Joy
the joy of seeing these girls
being articulate today
talking truth to power to the head of
villages telling them no one is touching
us anymore no one have the right to
touch my boob no and they are adamant
I mean the joy I take in that is that
finally
you can speak up with no danger with no
fear
I mean empowering people to that point
make me more humble I don't even know
sometimes I'm like where's the hole and
I can drive in and disappear and let
them be
but they won't let me go they say we
want you to come and see us and then we
still learn from you but I learned more
from those girls than I can ever learn
from anybody
the joy of being in on stage is
different is planting seeds worldwide
for people to see what the capacity what
they are capable of how many time after
concert people will come to me and say
Angelique how can we help
and I'm like how can you help
come on
your neighbors start looking at them
you can volunteer your time for
homeworks there's so much you can do in
your own country don't think that Africa
is just the country where we need help
we don't need help we need collaboration
did you warm up your voice today yes it
did
what do you sing to yourself
to cheer yourself up what are you saying
and I like that was better than Prozac
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so glad you warmed up
when you see your Grammys
lined up
and they're all shiny and extraordinary
I'm not even going to name how many
because every time I do you get more and
then this
chat will date so the many multiple
Grammys that you have won when you look
at them do you
does it feel good it feels good and at
the same time as I said uh before it is
a responsibility
I mean
my work I've been nominated first time
at the grammy it was in 1993-94.
and the first Grammy I won was 2007.
and I said to people
don't take Grammy for granted it's not
about how many likes you have is what
you have to say
what you are bringing to the table
how you are impacting the world in how
you are changing the music business it
is as it is
and
for me
that responsibility is always at the
core of everything I do
when I'm I'm setting myself to write new
songs I don't think about Grammys all I
think about
how would this song would help people
what impact it gonna have
I know you plan I know you have ideas
about what you want to do next for many
artists it would be you know how do you
want to spend your Sunset years but you
have extraordinary longevity in your
family so you have another half a
lifetime students
we are going to be going to a 100 year
old Angelique
and you're still gonna be let's go yeah
I'll be right in their own yeah so it
feels kind of weird to talk about Legacy
but what do you want people who follow
your work admire your work
see joy in your work what do you want
them to take away
from it well what I want people to take
away from my work
is their own worth
people's worth
we have too many people that think that
they are worth nothing
and absurd me that hurt me
and
when you give birth to a child
when a human being is coming out of your
body
Everything Changes
priorities
what matters you learn to go to the core
of things
what I want people to remember is that
you can fall beneath the Earth
but you always can rise
it does not matter how hard it is get up
and live your life
you know it and that's how we roll
I love you me too since the first time I
met it was a love story